let's now we've gone through all the
Senate candidates we're going to make
our way to the congressional candidates
and we'll start with the fourth district
which we're in right now and uh Carolyn
McCarthy again is not able to attend
however however she did she did bring a
representative and I would like to give
the warm welcome to Bill Lucas
[Applause]
[Music]
I know not how the uh Israeli ambassador
to to the uh un
feels um Congress goes on its August
recess next week so there are
legislation pieces that they're trying
to finish up before that recess and
that's uh she asked me to represent her
because I've worked with her in her
office through my uh position in APAC
the America Israel public affairs
committee which I think most of you
probably are aware of is an organization
which is dedicated to fostering the
United States Israel strategic
relationship uh it's working with her
and her office both in Washington and in
uh New York that I know her as a member
of both Long Island Council and the
Northeast Council of
AAS so with that in mind you don't need
me to stand up here and tell you that
we're living in very challenging times
not just for the United States but
especially for Israel uh it's under
attack attack in terms of security
threats the Iranian threat which is an
existential threat for it its right to
self-defense the Goldstone the aftermath
of the flotilla and various pressures
regarding peace initiatives and
increased efforts to really challenge
its legitimacy as a
state I believe and I believe the
congressman believes that under these
circumstances we really need to Rally
behind those that support us and us as
Israel and the United States and the
relationship between those two countries
not just when it's expedient in the
short term but those who've been
consistent and reliable over the long
term in terms of that support if you
look at Carol McCarthy's record she has
been a consistent reliable supporter
over her seven terms in
Congress despite the ups and
downs of the various administrations
over 60 years of Israel's existence the
support of the US Congress has been Rock
they've
continuously they have continuously
acknowledged the Strategic and mutually
beneficial relationship between Israel
and America and acted
accordingly under the Constitution the
role of Congress that is the house and
the Senate according to article one of
the Constitution as it relates to
Foreign Affairs is threefold number
number one appropriate funds number two
regulate commerce and number three
declare war that is the Constitutional
charge for the Congress in addition the
Senate has the charge of ratifying
treaties under article two of the
Constitution foreign policy and Foreign
Affairs are the domain of the executive
branch Congress has
the ability to utilize its power of
persuasion but it does not have
jurisdiction over foreign policy or
foreign okay so let's get specific okay
I totally agree with what uh Bruce
blakan said let's judge by deeds and not
by words okay so let's take a look at
carollyn McCarthy's voting record over
the seven terms that she's been in
Congress shall we
isn't it number one she has voted for
every foreign Appropriations Bill during
her 10e in Congress including the most
recent which granted $3 billion in Aid
to
Israel there was one attempt in
1999 to have Israel singled out and have
a cut she voted against that bill she
voted for the one time that Israel was
granted by Congress specific
appropriation in the aftermath of the Y
River Accords in
1999 for $1.8
billion during her tenure the house has
passed 11 different bills related to
Iran she has voted for each of them in
addition she co-sponsored seven of those
bills including HR
2194 which was the bill that was passed
just a couple of months ago which was
the comprehensive sanctions Act which
put penalties on any companies in the US
that were assisting anything in Iran
with refined petroleum and as was
mentioned the European Union just uh
came along with that report or that
those sanctions just last week she
assigned every house letter to the
president and the Secretary of State
regarding Iran and the actions that we
should take she's co-sponsored
resolution repudiating the Goldstone
report in November of' 09 in January of
09 she co-sponsored the resolution
supporting Israel's right to
self-defense after operation castled in
Gaza she co-sponsored in May of 2008
ongoing Palestinian rocket attacks on
Israel she co-sponsored a bill
recognizing Jerusalem as the capital of
Israel and saying that US Embassy should
be moved to is to Jerusalem she voted
for a resolution more recently
condemning the British University and
college union vote to boycott Israeli
academics and academic institutions she
has voted for literally dozens of
resolutions and signed letters from
Congress to both the president and the
Secretary of State supporting Israel I
think you get the point I hope you get
the point the bottom line is that in her
seven terms of Congress she has voted
for every single pro-israel piece of
legislation and she has signed every
single pro-israel letter that's been
issued this is consistent reliable
support that in these times I think are
worth noting and at least giving credit
for it she's on the subcommittee of the
House Education labor committee and she
also sits on the financial services
committee despite not being a member of
the Foreign Affairs committee she serves
as a member of the Democrat
Israel working group she favors a
two-state solution as will be negotiated
directly between the Israelis and the
Palestinians and it's obvious that she
has an understanding of the geopolitical
realities that Israel faces but she's
taken it even further she's traveled to
Israel several times to see and talk to
people on the ground both political
military and just common folks she's met
often with APAC I'm with APAC I'll tell
you I meet with her several times during
the course of the year and she's at
other things as well as well as with the
Jewish Community just last Monday she
met with seven rabbis from the South
Shore uh and by all accounts that was a
very successful meeting so when she
speaks it's not platitudes but it's
words and actions based upon knowledge
firsthand experience and longterm solid
commitment let me just end with three
statements in her words which I I think
makes it Crystal Clear one I will
continue to support efforts that
reaffirm support for Israel as a
longtime friend Ally and strategic
partner of the US and Israel's right to
defend itself two Iran is a threat not
just to the US and Israel but the world
and is a real threat against Global
safety we cannot just sit and watch Iran
three we must do all that we can to
ensure the security of the state of
Israel and its people just as the United
States is vital to the survival of
Israel Israel is also Sur vital to the
survival of the us our countries are
linked together on so many levels these
are the words of a person who in her
seven terms has voted and acted as a
solid friend and Spa proponent of us
Israeli relations in these challenging
times and they certainly are for both I
hope that we can rally around those that
have supported us over the long run and
have a proven history of friendship and
continuing to support us in the future
her record speaks for itself judge her
by her record
thank and by the way if I may I'd like
to answer the last question that we're
not signing on to Peter King Bill and
Carol McCarthy did not sign on to that
bill not because of its statement as
related to Israel but they was a piece
of that that recommended that required
the United States to withdraw from the
United Nations Human Rights Council
that's a position by the way
that and a believe that is not in the
best interest of Israel
[Music]
or I'm not right
person car
one of the statements let me let address
said direct um the first statement that
she made came out the day after the
cotilla uh incident on June 1st and the
second letter came out the second
statement came out on June 9th and yes
someone like me did have influence on
that second letter okay the first letter
however was not fully published in
Jewish star that's where you're coming
one of the quotes that I cited was out
of that letter and that was the one um
that talked about continuing its right
to defend itself and she also said
whenever there is loss of life it's
deeply regrettable but we must press
forward to ensure that all nations
recognize Israel's right to exist and
keep its people safe I'll just say two
things as far as that's concerned
one she was as I think most of you know
um a crime victim herself and then her
husband they will be
sensitive number
two number two gold of my ear who I
think all of us know was famous for many
things but one of the quotes that I most
respected gold the for was she said you
know eventually I can forgive the
Palestinians for killing my children but
I can never never forgive them for
making me kill theirs sometimes killing
is necessary but it's nothing that is
ever not regrettable if you know any
soldiers if you know anyone who has been
in a combat situation they don't get joy
from killing they don't kill because
it's fun and they don't get
gratification from it it's something
they have to do it's a dirty job and
it's a shame that people have to when I
worked in Israel I lived in Israel for 2
years one of the people who worked for
for me was on the Israeli squads in
Europe that were killing Black September
people in the aftermath of the unich
Olympics okay I will tell you for a fact
I had long talks with that man and he
killed some really bad people he got no
satisfaction out of that it was his
job so let's look at it in context she
supports Israel through her action and
that's the bot
[Music]
directly between the Israelis and the
Palestinians so what she's saying is
that the Israelis and the Palestinians
have to come up with something between
themselves which recognize both of their
aspirations not an imposed settlement
which is a position that the current
government of Israel takes it's the one
that the Omare government and all
governments I think over the last 10
years have taken this we
okay thank you